vingt-quatre heures après son
intronisation au panthéon le vésinet
rang d une nouvelle fois hommage à sa
façon à joséphine baker une personnalité
qui a vécu dans la commune de 1929 à
1947 une table ronde sur les oeuvres
écrites autour de sa vie était organisée
ce mercredi 1er décembre
jean claude bouillon bakker le cinquième
fils adoptif de l'artiste avait fait le
déplacement moi j'aime beaucoup cette
ville je m'étais j'étais venu déjà ya
quelques années faire un débat et je
trouve que voilà il ya une réception en
charge de la sécurité toujours au
rendez-vous et libère l'occasion pour le
public de découvrir une bande dessinée
sur joséphine baker c'était de raconter
sous forme de roman graphique la vie de
joséphine baker de sa naissance jusqu'à
sa mort et c'est un livre qui fait les
500 pages quand même donc c'est assez
aujourd'hui l'une des sommes les plus
importantes sur la vie de joséphine
baker un rendez-vous à guichet fermé
l'événement attiré une centaine des
personnes un engouement qui ne surprend
pas la commune il ya beaucoup
d'attractivité quand on parle de
joséphine baker je pense pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que
d'abord c'est une très grande dame qui a
fait beaucoup de choses à dame aux mille
vies et puis le deuxième point c'est que
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a vécu
longtemps au vésinet donc pendant
pratiquement une vingtaine d'années dans
une très belle vie là qu'est la ville à
bolobo chaîne le cycle de rendez vous
sur joséphine baker se terminera ce
vendredi au vésinet une exposition d'une
douzaine de panneaux sur les souvenirs
de l'artiste est à découvrir dans le
hall de la mairie